one of the hottest spaces in the market
right now is wearables it's the
epicenter of height all of the big
consumer electronics companies are
piling into this space because they
sniff an opportunity next year there'll
be 1.3 billion smartphones sold so even
if a fraction of those guys buy a
wearable device or get one with the
phone they buy it's going to be a huge
market Samsung has been totally
relentless in the wearable space it's
amazing to think that only this time
last year they announced their first
product the galaxy gear here we are 12
months later and they announced their
fifth product in 12 months the gear s
which has a sim card built into it it
also has a curved screen so Santa is
exploiting the advantage in components
to try and do something different LG
burst onto the scene at Google i/o with
their first android wear watch they've
now followed the trend that was kind of
set by motorola and gone for a round
face with the LG G watch our that's
interesting because I think it echoes
the view that we feel that fashion is
very very important wearables if people
are going to wear these products they've
got to look good and that round more
traditional not seems to be resonating
with consumers sony use deeper this year
to announce two new products they have a
new SmartWatch based on Android wear
also they announced an evolution to
their smartband product so the Smart
Plan talk and that actually has an e-ink
display so great battery life but also
allows you to talk into the device so
Sonia definitely still in the game input
a style some now set and their foot
touching tracks none of the other
companies that put their hat in the ring
is asus and they've arrived with a watch
and a hundred and ninety nine dollars
and it's more affordable though a lot of
their watches are coming down to those
price points but for me the challenges
who's going to buy all these watches
there's so many from so many
manufacturers I think a lot of it is
going to come down not just a price but
the marketing as well and i'm not sure
coming like asus can invest to the kind
of levels that samsung and sony can and
if apple into the space goodness knows
what impact they're going to have